hey guys Pete here it's that time of the
week it's time for the weekly spoiler
report just to give you a warning if you
don't want to know what's going on at
the filming locations for Game of
Thrones season 7 or any of the cast news
then you won't want to watch this video
I do have a giveaway going on though so
check out one of my non-spoiler videos
that I just put out like my recap of the
history and more for the tourney at
Harrenhal video that just came out you
can learn how to enter my book giveaway
there and everyone else can learn about
it at the end of this video all right if
that's out of the way let's get into it
so we talked last week about how they
finished up all the filming in Seville
and then they were supposed to move to a
model bar Del Rio castle to shoot for
about a week we've seen this castle and
we've talked about in some of the
earlier videos but we weren't exactly
sure which one of the castles of the
Seven Kingdoms it would be it's an
eighth century Muslim Castle and it's
been renovated a bunch of different
times so there's several different
architectural styles and you know from
different eras and cultures this led to
some some confusion even though a lot of
us thought it would probably be
Highgarden we just didn't know then last
Saturday Korda palace magazine out of
Spain started dropping a ton of
photographs and they say that the scenes
do depict parts of Highgarden
they also said there will be a conflict
taking place inside the walls between
the Tyrells and the Lannister soldiers
in a follow-up article Korda palace also
said that they had a resident from the
town who's acting as the body double for
diana rigg who plays Elena tour Tyrell
then we got this picture of the
Lannister flag flying over the castle it
was a little bit confusing because we
weren't sure if this was an indication
that the Lannisters took over Highgarden
there is an alternate explanation
however though this castle could be
playing Casterly Rock too because as I
mentioned before their staff there's
definitely some different architecture
in the same compound this was further
backed up whenever grey worm showed up
on
set because according to sources he's
not going to be involved in any of the
Highgarden scenes instead he's going to
be the unsullied commander when his men
assault Casterly Rock so we talked about
it last week that both of these castles
would come up and it looks like they are
just using the actual same place there
may be other interior shots and
different things but so far the large
battle scene I told you that's coming up
that they haven't started filming yet
that looks like it's going to be around
Highgarden so it's a little bit
confusing but the way that I'm seeing it
is Daenerys and one of her dragons at
least is going to lead the Dothraki
horde in an ambush against Jaime Bronn
and the Lannisters who have just taken
over a nearby castle if you look at it
like that it sounds like they're gonna
take over Highgarden
since Casterly Rock is theirs but we'll
have to wait until they actually start
doing the battle scene and maybe we'll
learn some more the other crazy thing
about this particular shoot I mentioned
grey worm Watchers on the walls
reporting that they have information
from sources that grey worm and Miss
Andy's relationship will actually go
much further than in previous seasons in
fact there is a sex scene in the works
so I'm not even sure how that works so
I'm just gonna move on to the next thing
the next thing we got a photo from a
different castle trujillo castle with
the lannister flag as well like I said
this is where it gets confusing because
they said that grey worm was at the
other place for an attack on Casterly
Rock
but with this photo here it would say
that Trujillo is Casterly Rock
so either way there are two different
castles to get different castle
exteriors that are flying the lannister
flag which would mean that we can
definitely expect Highgarden to fall and
on that same day back from the other
castle we saw some photos of the cast
where it looks like there's a bunch of
beaten up Tyrell men that were headed to
the scene to shoot from there we got
some news from the north place called
Wolf Hill quarry in the hills above
Belfast I mentioned this last weekend we
saw a
picture from tormance Instagram account
where he had snow and his beard we got
some set pictures here that you can see
and there was no foot filming going on
at the time but you can see a lot of
stuff based on these photos they added a
bunch of fake snow and created a fake
icy surface which looks pretty much like
an iced over lake or you know some kind
of still body of water the green screens
are also pretty interesting you can see
that they could do different things at
different times here but green screens
make me wonder if there might be some
kind of white Walker action involved in
this particular spot either way it's
very likely this is north beyond the
wall and it's probably related to the
story that we heard earlier about the
crew bringing back a white to prove that
there's a serious threat going on up
there
even though filming is still not started
in Caesarea they are doing a lot of
preparation and we got some cool photos
of that and we even got a shot of James
Faulkner who plays randyll Tarly
practicing some horse riding we'll learn
a lot more about this once they start
shooting next week but the way it looks
is that the Tyrells get into a squabble
with the Lannisters
and then the Lannisters get attacked
after or ambushed by Daenerys and it
looks like there's a lot of different
stuff in these photos where they have a
lot of different wagons and different
things like that where they're
transporting stuff that they probably
got from Highgarden coy released a bunch
of photos from Trujillo and we found out
that there was a lot more extras
involved than what was originally
mentioned something like two hundred and
fifty extras so that's really up in the
air they're doing a bunch of different
stuff in a bunch of different places so
with some of the later reports we get a
little better idea after all that prep
we finally get to see some of the major
actors interacting at this site Jaime
and Bronn were seen shooting scenes atop
the walls with their guards standing
watch it's a cool picture where we see
that they're looking over talking about
you know they're having a conversation
we see the cameras boom out over over
top so even though we're seeing it from
a distance this will be a conversation
they're having
on top of the wall where they talk about
what they're gonna do now low CFA's
Raynaud's reported that the actors were
seen loading those barrels that we saw
on the carts and the previous thing that
would be in the big ambushed scene so we
can pretty much now say that this is
Highgarden
the Lannisters have taken over and
they're taking away the plunder when
they get attacked by the nares which
we'll get to see next week once they
start filming so some really cool shots
of the actors in their costumes and what
looks like a pretty great castle with
the Lannister flags flying over top
after that we got some news that a new
actor was joining the cast his name's
Tom hopper again lo siete Raynaud's got
some photos from hoy that showed him
together with James Faulkner who plays
randyll Tarly on a bench in the city
along with different rumors about him
showing up at gyms with Bronn and Jamie
because of the combination of the
locations and who he's with it's most
likely he's gonna be playing dick and
Tarly who we didn't meet last season and
was a different character from what I
understand Watchers on the wall say the
guy who played him last year maybe tied
up with something else
so we may be seeing this Tom hopper as
[ __ ] in this season I didn't know who
he was I guess he was on a show called
black sails which I've never watched and
another one named Merlin so if you're a
fan of one of those shows you probably
already know who he is
all roads seem to be leading back to
this major ambush scene so what they've
heard is is that Dickon and Randall will
both be fighting in that scene so it's a
pretty major role as you know he's the
heir to a great house so yesterday the
final news I'm gonna talk about came out
and this ties back to the wolf hill
quarry location that I was talking about
that had the green screens and
everything a few minutes ago Watchers on
the wall are reporting that their
sources are saying there's going to be
at least three weeks of filming at the
Wolf Hill quarry this is going to be
going on at the same time as the big
battle scene is going on in Spain so we
could be getting a ton of stuff over the
next few weeks just to give an idea how
this is gonna be according to those same
sources they say there's going to be 300
whites now if you remember last season
that was pretty impressive in the whole
two-door scene with all those people
that wasn't close to 300 whites so this
is going to be a truly gigantic
production up here plus if they're
shooting for three weeks I mean there
could be different scenes going on but
some of them are gonna be really
elaborate so they also had a bunch of
spoilers that they printed yesterday and
some of its things that we've already
heard and then some of it's a little bit
about old questions that have been sort
of hanging in the air
so the first thing is is that we find
out that Jorah does go to old town if
you remember his last scene he gets sent
away by Daenerys to cure his greyscale
so he ends up there he meets Sam no in
the books at least the maesters of the
Citadel have no real interest in curing
greyscale and as we know that people who
have it basically get sent away to live
with the stone men so they're gonna need
an inn as far as how that goes together
apparently Sam's gonna help him because
he's gonna find out that he's the son of
his former Lord Commander at the wall
the old bear Mormont the other spoilers
come from the north which it seems like
we haven't been talking about too much
since there's so much action going on
with battles elsewhere Watchers on the
wall is reporting though that the three
stark siblings who were there will
reunite that would be Santa aria and
bran what they tell is pretty close to
what we learn from the supposes plot
leak that came out a few weeks ago or
maybe a month ago now everything's happy
at first but then there's gonna be
conflict between Sansa and Arya where as
I mentioned way back when we heard that
these actresses might be on the same
stage that you know Ari has gone through
a lot of different things and even
though Sansa has as well they're just
the divide that was between them as when
they were children has just kind of
grown wider they're they're both been
through really tough times but their
position is completely different of
course Littlefinger is supposed to
realize that there's tension and then
he's going to try to take it
manage of that so it's pretty sit it's
pretty similar to what you know that the
Revit leak had mentioned doesn't say
anything else beyond that except to say
that there was that theory out there
that Sansa might have been pregnant with
Ramsay's child watches on the wall say
that they can definitely say that it is
not true
Sansa will not be or get pregnant in
season seven I never really thought this
was a thing like it didn't it never
really added up to me but I feel like
that's gonna bring a relief to a lot of
people who want Ramsay to be gone for
good I don't think anyone wanted to see
Sansa give birth to a new Bolton
offspring I mean I think we've all had
enough of him at this point but that's
pretty much it for everything that came
out it's a lot of stuff though I mean
I'm excited I wasn't really pumped up
about jor getting cured at the Citadel I
didn't think it was very consistent but
this does kind of make sense if there's
information there on how to cure it then
Sam's the guy to find it and this is a
move that he would definitely make he's
definitely going to help out someone
that he cared so much about you know his
son so I'm okay with that I feel like
all the stuff with Casterly Rock and
Highgarden is pretty exciting it makes
you wonder how it's all gonna go down
but if they if if the latest errs sac
Highgarden and they're taking stuff away
then things aren't gonna end well for
the queen of thorns that part is pretty
clear and even though she lost everyone
in the last season they would still I
mean for that reason really they have to
take her out you know I mean there's not
they can't really leave her around she's
their enemy until she dies basically so
that's all pretty cool the North stuffs
pretty interesting
I hope we get to see some shots of them
filming that stuff up there and I'm
really curious to see just how big these
scenes look I don't know if they'll be I
mean they're gonna be close sets but
with three weeks of filming in two
different locations I hope we get some
cool shots to see what everything looks
like so please like the video if you
found it enjoyable to watch and check
back next week I'll have a new one with
all this new stuff we're talking about
it's become a weekly thing I do it every
Saturday check out my other videos I put
out this
week make sure you subscribe so you can
keep up with that I'm on a pretty
regular schedule right now and I'm
trying to get out as many videos as I
can for Game of Thrones even though
we're in the long wait I do have a book
giveaway going on and I do want you guys
to enter so just make sure you subscribe
and leave a comment on this video or any
of the other videos where I mention this
particular giveaway when I hit 28,000
subscribers I am gonna be sending one
commenter on one of those videos a copy
of the new 20th anniversary edition of a
game of Thrones by George RR martin it's
a super nice anniversary edition and
you're definitely want to get a hold of
that if you're a fan of the show thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon